i had this roommate who was red-headed i
forgot his name aaron i think and he was
a and we gonna fight because
you know he
he would leave his bible around the
living room yeah right and so as a joke
i threw out like a penthouse and i put
it next to that
you know being that guy you know what i
mean so he i came home once and he was
crying on the couch
like what are you good bro what are you
crying about he goes
i masturbated to your
um right
so that oh yeah yeah
that comes on you dude what that is
on you
i know right so then i go well how do i
make it up and he goes come to church
with me you need to be oh
what right so i went to church with him
because he jerked off to something you
left out yeah yeah